and the spirit away from the nets and
their fans this was a season that had so
much promise one of the pre-season
favorites to start the year the brooklyn
nets and it all fell apart at multiple
iterations during the season yeah i mean
look
they signed and moving in 2019.
they thought things would be different
but a first round loss
and a sweep
boston
four in a row
after they lost in five to the nets last
year they answer back with their eighth
series sweep in franchise history last
down in the bubble against the sixers
and kyrie irving
kevin durant
head into the
off-season not a single game decided by
more than seven points
but all four belong to the boston
celtics and now they will await the
winner of the milwaukee chicago series
stan and i are headed to milwaukee will
have game five between the bucks and the
bulls on wednesday
coming up game five jazz and mavericks
for stan van gundy stephanie reddy the
rest of our terrific tnt crew led by tom
heights at andrew greathouse i'm brian
anderson so long from brooklyn we're
coming right back ernie johnson standing
by in our atlanta